bonjour eric zemmour vous revenez sur l'
annonce de dissolution du mouvement
générations identitaire et pour vous ces
gens là sont victimes du en même temps
oui écouter vraiment le lieu en même
temps c'est comme les herbes folles sa
part tout ça détruit tout ça on
territoire mac rognant cc c'est devenu
systématique là on a bien vu le gérald
arman avait dissout baraka city le ccf
deux associations islamistes
il lui fallait évidemment faire un
équilibre car la macro ni progressiste
étaient effrayés par ce soi-disant
virage islamophobe et donc c'est sûr
génération identitaire que c'est tombé
voilà je ne vois pas d'autres raisons
alors maintenant évidemment la justice
va être saisi l'administration va
fournir un dossier aux petits oignons
on commence à voir déjà sortir ceci cela
le préfet de saint gaudens a même saisi
le je crois le comité contre les
génocides les crimes de guerre les
crimes contre l'humanité pour enquêter
sur sur ces générations identitaire
c'est complètement démesuré c'est un
marteau pour écraser une mouche
mais il ya quand même matière juridique
dissolution mais vous savez l'année
dernière ils ont été déjà attaqué en
justice pour une opération semblable et
ils ont été relaxés qu'est ce qu'ils
font ils vont dans les alpes et dernière
ou dans les pyrénées cette année et il
montre que les frontières ne sont
absolument pas tenu contrairement aux
déclarations gouvernementales aux
déclarations du préfet etc
ils vont avec des banderoles il n'arrête
personnes il laurent et ne se prennent
ni pour des policiers pour des douaniers
il n'y a aucune violence simplement vous
comprenez il
ils font des opérations médiatiques ils
font des passions d'agit-prop que don
dont les extraits dans l'est de la
gauche et est coutumière mais quand
c'est la gauche c'est magnifique c'est
des opérations inventive et spontanée
quand ce n'est pas la gauche et que
c'est pour défendre les frontières
l'identité de la france pour lutter
contre l'immigration
alors là c'est horrible voilà c'est tout
il n'ya aucune violence il n'y a aucune
aucun aucun aucune appels à la haine
comme on dit aujourd'hui de façon
ridicule
non ce sont des prétextes attendez vous
dit que ce sont des héros des héros des
gens qui pratiquent la dénonciation à la
police
écoutez moi je trouve ça très patriote
de défendre ses frontières
pendant des siècles ceux qui défendaient
les frontières c'était des héros voilà
on les décors et aujourd'hui on les
criminalisent et on les envoie au
tribunal et on les dit son ca deux poids
deux mesures insupportable qu'est ce
qu'on fait contre les gens d'utopia 56
qui occupent des églises des l'hôtel
dieu pour protéger leurs sans papiers
comme ils disent qu'ils sont en fait des
clandestins qui eux ne respectent pas la
loi française ont fait rien contre eux
on les 10 ou pas que fait-on contre les
femen qui perturbe de nombreux
événements de façon brutale que fait-on
contre le patron de la ligue de défense
noire africaine qui traite les soldats
français morts au mali de terrorisme
tous ces gens là sont sont complètement
dans la nature et sont libres de tout
groupe de tout de toute sanction
au nom de la liberté d'expression je
trouve absolument scandaleux que les
gens les jeunes militants de génération
identitaire n'est pas la même protection
que toute démocratie doit à cette
fameuse liberté d'expression merci eric
zemmour